This week we're
going to take a look
at exactly what you DO
with the photographs
after you've made them.
And, once again, frankly we
could devote a full six week
course to just this idea
alone--presenting your work.
But we'll try to cover
this topic as best we can
in just a couple of tutorials
for you for this week.
So let's start
with a few figures
just to dissect them and get
you to think more about how
you create figures
with your images.
Let's first take
a look at a figure
that the researchers made
for a grant submission.
And here we see a
host of the pieces
of devices, and the full
devices, all labeled.
They wanted to show what they
were capable of creating--of
course which is important.
But there's so much
going on, the question
is whether we want to
bother looking anywhere.
By the way, just
a note, I didn't
make any of these
images of the research,
but I knew that a few of the
original images were in color.
So first of all, why
not use the color
renditions if you have them.
Now, let's concentrate on the
composition of the figure.
Why not somehow find a
way that makes some sort
of compositional sense?
So here, we re-ordered all these
devices according to scale,
so we're giving the
readers some idea
of how to look at
this very busy figure.
In addition, we removed
most of the labeling
and we created a
key to the images.
And that key would be
labelled with letters,
so that if you wanted more
information about this
particular image within the
figure, for example its scale,
like this one, you would then
find that letter in the caption
and get more information.
So, you might not agree (but
I hope you do) if you look
at them side-by-side, I hope
you see that, once again:
by simplifying, editing down
your figures to the essential
pieces, and organize
them to tell your story,
that the reader--and in this
case grant reviewer--enjoys
looking at your figure and
understands the contents
of your figure.
If you're using up space in
your article, your presentation,
or your grant
submission, why not
use that space so that the
viewers actually want to look.
In this example, you are
seeing two photographs
that I made quite a
while ago, depicting
two ends of a long device.
The device was too long
to get into one frame.
So the researcher used these
two photographs in one figure.
The left and the right
side of the device
are combined, indicating
that it's much longer,
as you can see
with this notation.
And we see all sorts of labels
and arrows and SEM inserts.
What I suggested first from
the very beginning is--please,
give us a little more
space to breathe!
So many figures are packed
so tightly with stuff,
and we actually don't know how
to even start looking at it.
So for example, adding
space around the perimeter,
is what I did here by inserting
the whole figure into an area
with a larger canvas size.
And then, I questioned
the labeling.
If you are labeling
within an image,
it's imperative to
simplify your labeling
and clean it up and
make it nice and neat.
And here's what mean by that.
Try to put all your labels
lined up as best you you can,
either vertically and
/ or horizontally.
Next, question
whether you really
have to use a combination of
upper- and lower-case letters.
Why not make all of
your labels lower-case.
Get rid of your arrows.
Arrows with arrowheads are
completely unnecessary.
They are distractions as labels.
Lines without the arrow
heads are much better to use.
They're just more refined.
Rethink your colors.
How about using blue
instead of fuscia?
Please?
So, I hope you agree that this
is cleaner way of labelling
your figures.
And, in the end, I also
questioned the need
for the SEM inserts.
I'm not sure we are really
see more information
about the structure
of the device
with these additional SEMs.
The optical image says
all that we want to say.
And so I would have
deleted the SEMs.
But if you insist on including
inserts (maybe because, you
just wanted to show that you
were capable of making them,
which is fine)...
At the very least, orient
the inserts in the way
that the rest of the
optical image is oriented.
Here we're rotating these
SEM inserts 90 degrees
to make them more relevant
to the full image.
And now let's look
at them side by side.
Once again, I hope
that you agree
that the re-do is a much cleaner
and simplified figure, which
makes it much more accessible.
Let's look at another figure.
This photograph up here,
made by the researcher,
shows the device.
And here you see
yet another point
of view of that same device.
Down here we have a CAD drawing
to represent an important part
of the device where E. coli
or traveling from one chamber
to another.
And this other final
piece of the figure
is a micrograph of that very
same important connection
between the two chambers.
The question is, number
one, are these photographs
more than "good enough"?
I know that we talk
about this a lot,
but it's really important
to think about it.
It's pretty clear when you put
a photograph in your figure,
it's important to have the
best photograph you can make.
I wasn't convinced
that these images were
the best they could
be, and so I offered
to make another
representation of the device.
And so, here, this is
the image that I made,
which, I hope you
agree, looks better.
We decided to replace the
first picture in the graphic.
The next question
is something I feel
pretty important to consider.
In this next photograph,
ask ourselves:
are we really giving
more information,
or, frankly, is
it just redundant.
So we collaboratively
decided that it's not
an important piece
in the figure.
It's not saying anything that
we are not already saying.
So we deleted it.
We're simplifying, we're
editing down the figure
to the essential pieces.
After I looked at other images
that they made in the lab,
I suggested that we
include a fluorescing image
from their files of E.
coli going from one chamber
to the next, to sort of
match the lower right
SEM of the same area.
And they agreed.
And what I also suggested was
to invert the fluorescing image
so that it would work well
with the rest of the pieces.
After all remember
fluorescence in this situation
is basically a
tagging technique,
telling us evidence
of the presence
of a particular structure,
in this case E.coli.
We are not measuring or
quantifying florescence--and
we'll talk about that later when
we discuss image manipulation.
So in this case
it's perfectly fine
to reverse the grayscale
image, making this piece easier
to read.
So we replaced the
image we deleted,
with this fluorescing image.
The researchers then decided
they preferred another CAD
drawing to replace the
first one, which is fine.
And finally, we aligned
and resized all the images
to give us equal framing.
So we finally came up with we
believed was a clearer figure.
Less redundant.
And it worked quite
well, as you can
see, in the published paper.
So we should compare
them side-by-side,
and once again, I hope you
can see that second one is
a marked improvement.
This is what we do on campus.
We work together in
groups to dissect
all sorts of draft submissions.
It really works very
well, I encourage
you to do the same
on your own campuses.
Here's another figure that
another group of researchers
put together.
The tin sulphide powder which
yields some information,
then becomes deposited--and
we see that somehow in an SEM
of that layer--and ultimately
the idea is to show how
the researchers fabricated
this solar cell.
It's about process.
So we went through
a whole series
of iterations and questions.
I've edited them
down here so you
can see a number of the
attempts by the researchers.
So when I came into
the picture, I first
questioned whether
the graph really had
to be included in this figure.
Perhaps it could be have
been placed elsewhere
in the article.
And then we discussed
whether it was
important to show the powder.
They asked that i come
up with another way
of portraying the tin sulphide.
I tried it in vials.
I then suggested putting the
SEM within an illustration,
showing the various layers.
And then I made a photograph of
the solar cell, which I think
is better from their
rendition, I hope you agree.
And we eventually evolved
the final figure into this.
We concentrated on the
picture of the solar cell.
Did not need the
vials of powder,
just showing the
layers of the material.
Much easier for the reader
to see and understand what
is going on in this figure.
Again, editing and simplifying.